on passe maintenant à notre chronique
info ou intox avec anthony st léger
bonsoir anthony pons ordre bonsoir à
tous et on commence ce soir avec une
mise au point oui vous avez peut-être vu
son témoignage a circulé sur les réseaux
sociaux pendant les fêtes de fin d'année
celui de karim un patient lors de son
c'est lui que l'on voit à l'écran lors
de son passage à l'hôpital en service de
réa montreuil près de paris donc réa
parce qu'il avait contracté le coville
il enjoignait les gens à se faire
vacciner lui qui n'avait pas choisi
cette voie là ce témoignage des sept
hospitalisations qui l'on est et ils ont
donné lieu à de fausses informations le
concernant le présentant comme un faux
malade plusieurs comptes complotistes
évoqué une mise en scène notamment parce
que dans ce reportage de nos confrères
de bfm tv notamment dans ce tweet il
était mentionné nice ici une information
sur le chu de nice et dans le bandeau
comme on dit dans le jargon jargon
montreuil donc en seine-saint-denis a
rien à voir avec nice face à cette
ambiguïté est assez à différentes
informations qui ont circulé nos
confrères de bfm tv ont d'ailleurs même
dû faire cette précision en réponse aux
tweets tout ça pour dire qu'il y avait
donc donné lieu à de fausses
informations le présentant comme un faux
malades d'autres l'avaient même confondu
avec sept autres personnes toufik un
patient en ré à lui à bordeaux eh bien
figurez-vous que le patient en question
karim est décédé le 20 décembre en
dernier en réa des suites du coc vide à
19 de quoi tordre le cou donc aux thèses
complotistes l'information nous a été
révélée par nos confrères de libé qui
ont fait donc tout ce travail de fact
checking est d'ailleurs le journal
municipal des lilas c'est là où il
travaillait depuis maintenant 19 ans lui
a rendu hommage vous voyez avec cet
encart karim pour abdelkrim azzaoui de
son vrai nom une pensée évidemment à ses
proches qui ont subit la double peine de
voir son nom sali car il m'était donc un
vrai patient kovy d'une vraie victime de
cette pandémie mais sur les réseaux
sociaux il existe aussi de faux patient
oui la vidéo que l'on va voir a été
publié le 11 décembre sur twitter se
compte par exemple plus de 6000 retweete
8000 j'aime le compte en question
relaient régulièrement des propos anti
vaccins on voit la vidéo on en parle
juste après
est ce là
une vidéo a raccourci cette femme et
nous explique quoi qu'elle joue le rôle
de malade dans un centre convient 2009
sans donner davantage de détails et le
compte twitter de légende etc c'est
chaud quand vous voyez ici et qu'elle
serait en train de simuler un arrêt
respiratoire de jouer donc le rôle d'un
patient aux prises avec le co vide cette
idée elle est reprise dans différentes
publications à grande échelle ici en
français où on en profite pour tacler à
les médias gros diffuseurs de fait nous
as est un classique partager ici sur
facebook où on évoque un spectacle donc
une duperie finalement l'idée sous
jacente sous jacente est temps que l la
pandémie serait donc fabriqué de toutes
pièces et que le taux d'occupation des
hôpitaux ne serait qu'un leurre mais ce
qui était intéressant de ce parce que
cette patiente est bien une fausse
patiente qu'ovide 19 audrey est ce qui
est intéressant c'est de se pencher sur
le contexte d'origine on va faire ça en
trois étapes si vous voulez bien d'abord
la première on va rechercher les
mots-clés fake patiente nous donc en
allemand et en anglais pour faux patient
on tombe sur un nombre d'utilisateurs de
instagram official mais lisa et quand on
tape ce nom on tombe sur le compte de
cette install rameuses germanophone vous
voyez cette vidéo est en tout cas des
extraits de cette vidéo en question des
stories qui ont été publiés le 10
septembre 2020 elle explique qu'il
s'agit d'un test dans un nouveau centre
qu'ovide à elle précise qu'elle n'est
pas malade sur le linge de lit à
plusieurs reprises on peut voir le nom
vivante est vivante est c'est le nom
d'un groupe hospitalier berlinois ça
nous amène à la troisième étape on
recherche les mots corona zentrum pour
centre qu'ovide eu bon pour exercice est
vivante est ce donc obtient ton on
obtient un communiqué du 11 septembre
2020 il émane du groupe vente est donc
qui évoque précisément un entraînement
dans un centre de batte de traitement
contre le coc u19 on est à berlin leur
page facebook s'en fait également l'écho
on apprend que l'exercice a eu lieu la
veille le 10 dates de publication donc
des story de l'insta gras meuse et que
70 figurants ont joué le rôle de
patients fictifs pourquoi pour former
les soignants face à l'afflux de malades
on est le 10 septembre 2020 donc au
début de la pandémie et de préciser que
ce rôle de patients et assurer
bénévolement et d'ailleurs l'installera
meuse a dû même elle faire une
explication sur son compte instagram
parce que sa vidéo a été tronquée
décontextualisés elle a tenu à clarifier
les choses a bien dire qu'elle prenait
toutes ses distances avec ces propos oui
cette femme est une n'est pas malade du
copic 19 mai on a quelqu'un ça aîné
était une actrice payer pour jouer une
patiente du coc vide donc pas de faux
patient qui remplissent les hôpitaux
mais c'est un fox liés aux faux patient
n'est pas nouvelle non effectivement
cette même en fox avait circulé déjà le
jour même de cette publication le 10
septembre on la voyait sur twitter ou
des comptes affirmait photos à l'appui
que cette scène à visait justement à
légitimer les mensonges liés aux kobe 19
et de manière générale depuis le début
de la pandémie les vidéos et qui veulent
montrer que cette pandémie précisément
n'est qu'une mise en scène notamment au
moyen de faux patient pullulent je vous
renvoie à l'un des exemples déconstruit
par l'équipe des observateurs c'est sur
france 24 points comme évidemment merci
beaucoup anthony sent léger on commence
bien l'année avec vous comme cette
édition selon marc une courte pause et
on se retrouve dans un instant à tout de
suite
[Musique]